après des semaines de soulèvement à
travers toute la tunisie c'est ici au
coeur de la capitale tunisienne sur
l'avenue habib bourguiba que des
centaines de milliers de tunisiens
s'étaient donné rendez vous pour
célébrer cette victoire le départ du
président zine el abedine ben ali après
23 ans de pouvoir alors dix ans après
que reste-t-il de cette journée
historique que sont devenus les raids et
surtout les espoirs d'une vie meilleure
de tout un peuple tunisien
comme beaucoup de jeunes tunisiens
jawher militante de la première heure
s'interroge sur son avenir
il y a dix ans pourtant elle faisait
partie de ceux qui fêtait le changement
politique
après des semaines de mobilisation et
d'affrontements avec la police
mère d'un petit garçon de 4 ans cette
jeune fonctionnaire de l'éducation
nationale ne veut pas perdre espoir même
si tous les voyants de l'économie sont
au rouge
j'étais tellement heureuse de cette
révolution je n'arrivais pas à y croire
qu'enfin le peuple tunisien décide de se
soulever car moi mon engagement ne date
pas de la révolution j'étais déjà engagé
politiquement contre le système
j'écrivais sur les réseaux sociaux
j'étais très souvent censurés j'ai même
été blessé par balle durant les
premières heures du soulèvement
j'ai eu beaucoup d'occasions de quitter
mon pays même avant le départ de ben ali
mais pour moi ça a toujours été une
option inconcevable ici c'est chez moi
et c'est ici que je veux vivre auprès de
mes amis de mes proches et de la famille
et que mon fils grandisse ici dans son
pays
a sidi bouzid épicentre du printemps
arabe
le coeur ne semble pas être à la fête
pour ce dixième anniversaire de la
révolution
les rêves d'une grande partie de la
population reste plombée par une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent en
tunisie
le taux de chômage avoisine les 15 % est
atteint m
30% dans les régions les plus touchées
comme le gouvernorat de sidi bouzid
la tunisie n'est plus un pays la tunisie
demeure entre les mains d'une poignée de
corrompus de malfrats et de voleurs à
sidi bouzid
les gens n'en peuvent plus on a atteint
un point de non retour
nous n'avons pas le coeur à la fête
nous sommes en deuil depuis dix ans et
chaque année sidi bouzid pleure sa
révolution
et cette colère est d'autant plus
palpable chez ceux qui étaient prêts à
sacrifier leur vie pour un avenir
meilleur où elle se souvient de ce mois
de janvier 2011
opposants et militants il avait été
arrêté puis torturé par les forces de
l'ordre pour ses engagements et ses
prises de position anti ben ali
aujourd'hui il déplore un recul des
quelques progrès enregistrés le 5
janvier j'étais étudiant à sousse et
c'est là que des manifestations ont
éclaté
on n'est qu'aux événements qui avaient
éclaté à sidi bouzid et kasserine
ceux qui ont fait la révolution que nous
connaissons tous aujourd'hui à l'aube la
police a frappé la porte de chez moi m'a
traîné hors de mon lit pour me conduire
au commissariat
j'ai passé 48 heures en garde à vue les
6 et 7 janvier 2011
quarante huit heures de torture que vous
ne pouvez même pas imaginer
j'ai été frappée suspendu la tête en bas
brûlé avec des cigarettes et j'en passe
le lendemain je terminais en prison si
beaucoup semblent avoir baissé les bras
il demeure positif il veut toujours
croire au renouveau
dix ans après le mouvement qui avait
réveillé les consciences dans le monde
arabe
parmi toutes nos revendications la seule
chose qu'on a gagné c'est la liberté
d'expression et même cette seule
victoire reste remise en cause jour
après jour tant qu'il resterait une
cause à défendre
il restera des gens pour lutter et la
victoire finira par arriver peut-être
pas notre génération mais celle d'après
notre devoir est de nous accrocher à nos
droits et lutter pour il n'y a aucune
raison de perdre espoir
à la fin la justice triomphe toujours
impossible aujourd'hui de ne pas
ressentir ce pessimisme ambiant et ce
sentiment de désespérance largement
partagé par la jeunesse tunisienne
à l'heure où certains ont préféré la
voie de l'immigration clandestine ou
celle de l'économie informelle
d'autres veulent encore y croire pour
qu'enfin germer les fruits d'une
révolution tant espéré